this year is the International Year of
pulses events are happening around the
world to raise awareness of the
important role that pulses play in food
security and nutrition being rich in
protein minerals environments pulses can
form an important part of a healthy diet
we want people to come and see what they
are eating on the daily basis at this
event organised by the IAEA in
partnership with the UN's Food and
Agriculture Organization people learned
about the benefits of pulses and got to
taste them too before I never used too
much you know beans in my regular food
but now I think I should because it's
not only cheap but also very very
healthy a nuclear technique can be used
to develop improved varieties of plant
crops including pulses it's known as
mutation breeding and has been used
since the 1930s the mutant varieties of
pulses they are more adaptable to
climate change resistant to diseases and
also they have high yield and rich in
minerals and proteins pulses also
contribute to improving soil fertility
they absorb atmospheric nitrogen into
their roots and release it into the soil
where it's available for the next
generation of crops this is a form of
natural fertilization and reduces costs
for farmers a new clear technique and
find out which pulses are the most
effective by using
isotope of nitrogen nitrogen 15 we can
determine how much each time is fixing
and then we can then transfer this
knowledge to our member states
eventually to the farmers that they grow
those high fixing variety pulses have
been cultivated for over 10,000 years
but it's only recently that their true
value as a nutrient for both people and
soil has been recognized now pulses such
as these lentils are seen as a powerful
superfood in a key crop to sustainable
development in a first century from
Vienna Austria this is Alexandra no
panic reporting for the IAEA